تغطي نصف فدان بالزهور المعلقة
، أقدم الوستارية المعروفة في
اليابان هي محور هذه
الحديقة المزهرة الملونة بألوان الباستيل الرائعة
[موسيقى] التي
تقع في مدينة تو صفيق اليابان على بعد ما يزيد قليلاً عن
ساعة بالقطار من طوكيو وهي
حديقة أزهار في شيكاغو تمتد الحديقة على 23  فدان
وهي موطن لأكثر من 350
زهرة غامضة وأخرى تختلف الألوان
باختلاف موسم الإزهار من الوردي
والبنفسجي إلى الأصفر والأبيض
.
هي المعجزة العظيمة الوستارية ،
الشجرة المترامية الأطراف التي يبلغ عمرها 140 عامًا تقع
في مكان فخر في
وسط الحديقة بعد حلول الظلام ،
يضيء الموقع بحيث يمكن رؤية هذه الزهور اللفافة
في جميع
الساعات ، حيث تبدأ الوستارية الصفراء
الزاهية في التفتح في  بداية شهر مايو وهي
الوحيدة من نوعها في اليابان ، تعد الحديقة
نقطة جذب على مدار العام مع
النباتات الموسمية التي تخلق
إحساسًا متغيرًا بالروعة مثل الطبيعة
يقدم لك
[موسيقى]
لك